you're in Budapest and you feel like
having a drink there's vodka gin rum
lemonade but this would all be a mistake
because in this city you have to indulge
in a glass full of Hungarian history
well actually three to be exact
meet pálinka Unicom and soda water
[Music]
without further ado let's bring in our
experts
first up Zoltan who heads up the house
of Hungarian pálinka in Budapest Paul
Anka the strong spirit it is a 100%
fruit juice delight barranco is deeply
woven into the fabric of Hungarian
society everybody knows what is the
history of pálinka began in 1300s when
the Queen and the king of Hungary or the
Torah was suffering from gout they
stumbled upon this earlier version of I
think that which they used to cure
themselves is made from a huge variety
of fruit apricots - plums - cherries -
pest rifles and we've heard it's quite
strong
the usual alcohol content is typically
between 40 and 50% 60% some higher can
your unikom beat that schandle we can't
beat it but we can match it because we
also have 40% so Unicom is a bitter
herbal liqueur there's a roughly 10
million hungarians
and we sell yearly four million bottles
it was invented in 1790 by my ancestor i
am the sixth generation see this dr.
sparke
was the position - the Emperor of
Austria Hungary and when the emperor had
a bad stomach my ancestor made him una
cone which is made of 40 different kinds
of herbs and spices their recipe is a
secret so I can tell you that for
example we use vanilla or ginger okay
I mean okay I told you - that's
that's enough a few non-drinkers there's
soda water a staple on Hungarian tables
this is Lazlo and his father Leo so
there is a young man thank you gentlemen
kiss last lo see Chris casita de la
Concorde Orbison have seen the oxidation
visa day and the Columbus LED TV for my
hat for many business in yolks in the
latter me and tomorrow two equalities a
theater and a Minda duty as I call the
cafe on
no wonder lashline knows his stuff it
was in hungry where the large-scale
production of soda water started annual
says huzzah avec inventor out of the
applications because Apple Auto V rangas
eco so the reason account for just a
shop having technology at each Aki a
pastiche martinakhaelss emigrated value
or the air will show you the context
washing I get my glad shall we taste
them together bombs up gents our
Strong's good drink there's again that
was great
[Music]